(playful, upbeat music)
- [Voiceover] Money.
It's everywhere.
But what happens when your bills get old
and need to be replaced by new ones?
That means old cash needs to be destroyed.
A lot of cash.
This is not, however, the story
of money growing on trees,
but of trees, growing out of money.
Well, more like vegetables.
(bright music)
- We are here at the Federal
Reserve Bank in New Orleans,
and this is where we
shred millions of dollars.
My name is Dean Wortha, I'm
the lead business analyst
for cash services here
at the New Orleans Fed.
We are the nation's bank.
Our job is to make sure that
we have a supply of currency.
Also part of that is to
ensure that we remove unfit,
old dirty currency from circulation.
So here on average, we shred
about six million dollars
in dirty money every day.
This could be for any number of reasons.
It could be because the
note has rips in it,
holes in it, tears in it.
It could have tape on it,
it could have graffiti
written all over it.
We don't want that note
going back into circulation.
If it has any sort of those qualities,
it will be shredded.
What we used to do is take
all of these currency shreds
and they would just wind up
as waste, going to a landfill.
Now, through a lot of work and effort,
we finally figured out a way
where we can take these shreds
and ultimately recycle them.
- [Voiceover] So all
that green leaves the Fed
and heads to a compost facility
where it turns into
something quite useful.
- What you're looking at right
now is 24 million dollars.
But the soil that is
creates will be priceless.
My name is Johnathan Christian.
We turn cash into soil.
It is definitely one of
our secret ingredients.
It's little in content, but
it's huge in what it provides.
Currency that's deemed unfit
is brought to our facility
at Wooden Materials.
From there we go through
a simple composting process
where we convert that into a healthy soil.
Our compost is used
primarily by urban farmers
in the greater New Orleans area.
- [Voiceover] One of these
farmers is Simond Menasche.
- And this is a million dollar farm.
We are making fresh, local
food accessible in New Orleans.
We've grown veggies, herbs,
cucumbers, tomatoes and peppers.
The vegetables we grow here are
made out of composted cash.
It is very fulfilling to be growing,
using a material that would
otherwise go to waste.
One man's trash is another man's treasure.
- [Voiceover] And that's the story
of how we grow tomatoes out of cash.